this is a production of Cornell
University
I do want to acknowledge that like I'm
I'm getting to share the work today here
but there's a lot of other collaborators
uh pis that uh have helped bring this
work and it definitely doesn't happen
alone and so some of the people that
I'll mention today uh Dr Steve Larson is
a USDA research scientist at Logan Utah
uh Dr Jesse Poland started some of this
work when he was at Kansas State and is
still collaborative on it and then Dr
Lita Hahn is the uh breeder for the
intermediate wheatgrass at the land
Institute so he does a lot of the the
Hands-On field work providing the data
that I get to analyze and work with and
show you today
um so the the talk for today just really
uh a four different parts provide a
little bit of introduction for
intermediate wheatgrass uh what it is
what we're trying to do and then we'll
spend most the time on the this breeding
uh for crop development looking at the
intermediate wheatgrass breeding cycle
and some of the the results we're seeing
and finally uh conclude kind of with
some population genetics what can you do
with the data and and where uh we're
trying to go in the future with some of
this work
so the the first thing and I know there
is actually research at Cornell within a
pyram intermediate but most the time
most audiences the the first thing is
just you know what is this plant it's
intermediate wheat grass so centiparum
intermedium the grain is being marketed
under the name kernsa uh so I usually
use uh iwg but if I say Kearns uh we're
talking about the the same thing the
grain there and it is a perennial plant
that we're looking at a
neo-domestication for ecosystem services
so things like reduced nitrate leaching
reduce soil erosion increased carbon
capture that you can do with these
perennial root systems compared to our
annual crops
and just looking a little bit at what do
you do with this grain uh some different
products Patagonia has released this
long root ale I know this one is on the
the West Coast I'm not sure if Patagonia
has released the an East Coast version
of this uh Cascadian farm so a
subsidiary of General Mills uh you know
one of the the largest cereal makers
released this uh limited edition serial
and then a lot of small scale breweries
bakeries are making products from
Pennsylvania there's Columbia County
bread and granola making these uh
sprouted Kerns a crisp or little chips
so there's a lot of different uh
utilization of the grain everything from
breads to Brewing uh
so looking at where all of this started
just to get a brief timeline in the
1980s a lot of this the ideas started at
Rodell Institute in Pennsylvania they
evaluated over 150 different perennial
species looking for uh what they thought
was the the main target that could be
more easily domesticated and
intermediate was the The Chosen species
uh in 2003 that work moved to the land
Institute with Lee De Haan and Lee
completed about six breeding Cycles from
2003 up to 2016 and in 2017 is is when
we started uh genomic selection up to
today uh going from cycle seven this
year right now we're in in breeding
cycle 14.
so when we look at breeding intermediate
wheatgrass
um you know the four big traits we look
at it's non-shattering free threshing
seeds
seed size or seed mass and then then
grain yield right now intermediates
about 10 percent of annual wheat so that
really needs to be increased to be a
viable crop for Farmers to to grow and
plant and and want to use as far as
breeding it is an outcrossing uh
heterozygous perennial the genome is a
little bit smaller than bread wheat but
it's still uh you know 12.6 GB so it's a
quite large and then it's also a
perennial as well
so before genomic selection the the
traditional phenotypic breeding cycle
would look a lot like this you would
take your parents in the spring you
could cross those and intermate those
you would get seed off your parent
plants that that fall you could start
seedlings
uh it would overwinter and then you know
the summer of year number two you would
collect phenotypic data you can take
that phenotypic data back analyze it go
figure out which plants you wanted to to
bring back in and make your next cycle
of selection with
so this takes um
at a minimum two full years per cycle
and the the one equation we'll really
look at today is just rate of genetic
gain we won't we're just going to look
at it uh
uh with with letters we're not going to
get into numbers or you know calculating
but just in general we know that rate of
genetic gain is the intensity of
selection
the accuracy
the genetic variation all divided by the
the time to complete the breeding Cycles
so in this uh example you know it takes
us two years to complete the breeding
cycle uh being a perennial plant maybe
we want to know how does that plant
respond in years two and three if we
were to do those evaluations then it
just adds more time to the breeding
cycle driving your your genetic gain
down and the first three Cycles at the
land Institute were were three years per
cycle so that's how from 2003 to 2016
there were only six cycles of selection
so I started this work uh really in 20
uh fall of 2016 looking at how do we
Implement genomic selection yeah that
was my my task as a as a postdoc is we
want to implement it how do we do this
this is kind of the the schematic we
came up with it looks a lot like your
your phenotypic selection starting out
you can cross your parents uh you get
seed seed off of those parents then in
the fall when you start those individual
seedlings
those get tissue sampled genotyped and
we can predict right away on those
seedlings that are only a couple weeks
old which ones we think are going to
have the the best trait values and we
start about 4 000 seedlings 100 are
selected each year for parents so you
can go in and grab those hundred that
you want for parents move them to the
greenhouse and right away they can be
intermated forming seed for the Next
Generation
now there is a a second component with
this so we can uh complete the breeding
cycle but we want our genomic selection
model uh to keep being updated so the
the second part is we take the the
non-selected plants we take those out in
the field they can be evaluated the the
second year the third year and all of
that data can go back into
forming the the predictions for the
following Cycles so our training
population is always uh at least one
cycle behind what we're actually
selecting
but following this scheme you can get
your uh reader's equation the rate of
genetic gain just down to the intensity
uh the selection accuracy and genetic
variance because we're down to one year
per cycle
um so so thinking about how this works
again just the the Breeders equation
those various components uh under
phenotypic selection uh we can we can
vary each part of this equation and one
area that we work on is selection
intensity under phenotypic selection uh
lee would plan out ten thousand plants
and then select the best hundred so
that's an I value of 2.65 under genomic
selection just based on cost constraints
we only genotype about 4 000 and we
still select about a hundred for the
Next Generation so uh our I value is
2.38
so in this case when we look at genomic
selection to phenotypic selection the uh
we're at 0.87 so we're not actually
selecting as hard on the population with
genomic selection as we are under under
phenotypic selection
so that's selection intensity
and then our big gain is in selection
accuracy where we can complete that
breeding cycle in half the time
uh which should give us essentially
double the the yield of or double the
the gain compared to phenotypic
selection
so you can simulate this and all of
these different variables particularly
intensity and time that's the two things
that we can really manipulate with
genomic selection and we can put
together kind of a curve of where we
think uh we can end up for particular
traits so on this uh this figure the the
time axis that's the genomic selection
divided by the excuse me phenotypic
divided by genomic selection time so
from the last slide you know we were at
0.05 so we were at half the time of
phenotypic selection
excuse me y-axis is intensity and in
this particular case you know we were at
0.89 and then our relative efficiency or
relative gain of genomic selection to
phenotypic selection is is where uh we
are on this response surface
so using the the values
um from the last slide and this trait is
for just grain yield Spike yield our
selection intensity is a little bit
lower under genomic selection but we're
still doing that in half the time so we
should get to about a two and a half uh
time uh two and a half
relative efficiency gain using genomic
selection
and if you do look this response curve
actually doesn't set directly on this
line and that's coming from a little bit
of gain and accuracy I've used it just a
fixed variable but when we have our
genetic markers when we're making our
field adjustments we can actually make a
better prediction of that plot than we
could with pedigree records alone so
that's why we get a little bit coming
off of the the main line there
and you can do this with each trait
looking at different hair abilities and
this is uh basically what we put
together we thought for free threshing
we could get a relative gain of three
3.8 times our phenotypic selection
something that's highly heritable uh 6.6
and then Spike yield this is one of our
lower heritability traits everything's
is affecting Spike yield still get about
two and a half times the the relative
gain compared to phenotypic selection
it's all of that work that was kind of
the the setup to move toward genomic
selection uh we had a training
population that had been phenotyped and
genotyped all of the the slides before
that the data was built on those we knew
what our trade hair abilities were so
then we went to application and uh you
know how did we apply this and this is
just the the overview of of the breeding
cycle getting that uh entire cycle in
into one year uh and I usually think the
the breeding cycle starting in about
October and this is at the point that
we've selected those parents they're in
the greenhouse uh those seedlings are
growing bigger they're cloned so we have
multiple multiple ramets of each
individual Jeanette and by Jeanette I
mean a plant that is a single plant with
a genetic makeup so it's one single
heterozygous plant you could clone that
Jeanette into multiple ramets where each
ramet is the the same genotypically
so in the greenhouse these these ramets
uh they're cloned they're vernalized uh
then they're intermated uh the and then
around
April to may all of these breeding
populations you can thresh the seeds so
you've got the seed for the next cycle
so that's the the breeding cycle the
second part again is keeping that
training population updated uh at the
same time that the greenhouse work is
going on the validation or the training
population is out in the field so it's
being vernalized it's overwintering it's
growing and then uh in the summer
starting in May to July all of the
phenotypic data can be collected
and then the the final aspect what I
work on particularly is uh the genomic
selection and prediction which occurs uh
from about the first of August to the
the first of October and just zooming in
on that area
um so on the top you know we have August
at the far end October and these are the
the basic steps of the breeding program
everything that has to happen and I've
got the uh number of days approximately
that each one of these steps takes so at
the time that the the data is still
being recorded it's still being you know
compiled and checked this is going on
until mid-august uh the seedlings are
already started
once I get all of the data Lee to Han is
handling all of this data then it's a
pass off to me then we start running it
through our statistical models uh trying
to get the best prediction for our
as a training population to predict on
those new seedlings
tissue collection on about 4 000 plants
over a couple about a week and then we
have uh two weeks or so to do GBS
Library preparation
once those are sent off to a Sequencing
Center two to three weeks later we get
data back a lot of quality control check
in the data
and then once we call Snips impute the
data we're ready for the the genomic
prediction and this is uh I like to
describe it the genomic predictions
that's my one
one thing that I have to do each year
and it's only one day so I work one day
a year
uh now the the challenge is nothing can
go wrong that one day so I spend the
rest of the time making sure one day is
is perfect uh
once those predictions are made I pass
all that data back to Lee so you know at
the end and like I said it's a
collaborative effort I don't handle the
entire process I mean we have things
divided up with what we can do very well
and then he uses the breeder's eye and
and makes selection indices and selects
those plants that go into the the
greenhouse for mating and updating the
cycle
um when we started this we we did
publish this in the plant genome this is
the graph we published uh so tli cycle
six this was the last year of phenotypic
uh selection and then starting in 2017
we had cycle seven and this was
published in 2021 I've updated the
figure a little bit in 2023 we've got uh
the third year of data from cycle 10.
but I was like this is a little bit out
of date
uh this is today's breeding cycle so the
same
uh the same thing we saw on the last
slide but we've already got cycle 12 the
first year of data's just collected a
couple weeks ago and then starting this
year we've moved to a Rapid Cycling to
get two cycles per year so we're at
cycle 13 we completed that back in March
and we're working on Cycle 14 right now
so this has really allowed us to move
instead of discrete Generations cycle
six and then planting cycle seven for
one two or three years and then cycle
eight we can go through uh multiple
generations and we also have multiple
Generations they're never at the same
plant age but within one calendar year
were measuring
multiple Generations how that plants
responding so we we have hope that and
some evidence that we think this is
making our prediction models better that
we're doing better at incorporating all
the the G by E elements
so just I mentioned speed breeding uh
how are we doing that uh the just in the
greenhouse uh and then the timeline sets
up much the same way only the breeding
population it's really condensed that
under under red and far infrared light
we can grow these plants to get them to
tiller in about three weeks after
putting
a lot of red light on them
and so so we can start in October like
the normal breeding cycle by February uh
threshing seed
by mid-march the selections have been
made and now we're coming up on
completing that cycle again
and this is uh just
about 10 days ago so this is the land
Institute this is Cycle 14 the entire
breeding cycle that's been started and
genotyped there's Lee and suzzle stop it
is a postdoc with the land Institute at
the very end I'll share some of the work
that he's been leading and then this is
the the far red lights that we're
waiting once we get data back those
plants will go under right away
so the the two cycles per year this is
the
the proximate timeline we're following
that's our first year but it looks like
we're we're on track to to be able to do
this and at the same time that
Cycles are advancing in the greenhouse
we still have the the training
population growing in the field so
there's there's multiple moving Parts at
the same time
so the that was the the implementation
of genomic selection uh so the other
part of my job then is convincing the
breeder that what we're doing is working
and we've spent a lot of time looking at
different measures you know how can we
tell if our selections are working or
not
and you know one of the first things we
did was we had this predicted value on
the the seedling and then we have the
the training population about a thousand
plants that go to the field so we said
okay how well does this predicted value
actually measure the field data that was
measured seven eight months later and
this is free threshing so in cycle seven
uh on the x-axis is the predicted value
that we made in the fall of 2017 and
then the y-axis is the The observed
value from the field in 2018 so this is
year one I've got a correlation of 0.76
and multiple years so we this is the
same uh same cycle same plants we're
using the same predicted value that we
made but in year number two
so in 2019 so almost two full years
after we've made that prediction we
still get a very strong correlation so
this is free threshing uh we probably
have the better results for free
threshing shattering one of the lower
results is Spike yield so if we're
trying to increase yield a lot of
emphasis here the correlation is only
0.25 so in Year One
and then in in year two again using our
predicted value from 2017 and seeing how
it looked in 2019 a correlation of 0.21
which is is low but there's still a
trend there
another thing that we looked at then was
we had these hundred parents that we had
intermated that had been selected
ideally as you know the best individuals
to move that population parameters
forward
of the same generation a thousand of
those plants that were not selected as
parents went out to the field up there
training model but since it's a
perennial plant once these plants the
parents were intermitted in the
greenhouse they were still growing so
there was an idea okay let's put those
parents out beside the unselected of the
same generation
and so what you're seeing here is a
histogram of a free threshing so it's in
the at least the second year because the
first year those parents are in the
greenhouse then they've been planted
right beside the same field location
um there is some statistical issues the
parents aren't randomized you know
ideally the better parents are on the
edge
but for free threshing
if we make a histogram of the entire
population
that's the the black bars the mean of
the population is uh the the vertical
black bar but looking at this those
hundred parents those have been colored
in in purple the mean of the parent
population for free threshing uh ends up
being about 11 percent on a percentage
scale Higher free threshing than the
unselected individuals
and we can look at the the same traits
of Spike yield remember there wasn't a
strong correlation between predicted
value and observed but when we take
those parents out to the field again we
find that our parent plants are
outperforming the the unselected so just
giving some uh some data that we do feel
like our models are working so
confidence in what we're predicting
and looking at other traits so this this
is summarizing in a table the same type
of things we saw in that histogram so
we'll have the trait the the realized
selection differential how those parents
uh the mean value of the parents versus
the mean value of the population and
then using the heritability we can
estimate the expected response to
selection and percent genetic gain per
year
so for free threshing and this is one
that we we saw the histogram on the the
parents were about 11 percentage points
better than the unselected it ends up
being about a 14
per year genetic gain Spike yield the
parents were
0.11 grams better but we had a lower
heritability so our estimated or
expected response is only about 0.04
grams that still ends up being about
eight percent genetic gain per per year
for refreshing
so this is one of the the first things
we looked at and now we're up to
multiple Cycles we can look at the the
field data this isn't a common Garden
experiment but just looking at how those
Cycles individually are performing and
predicting uh the best The Blob for for
each individual sorting those into the
the cycle they came from
so on the x-axis we have the different
Cycles starting at cycle six all the way
to cycle 11.
and then the the distribution of those
individuals for Spike yield in grams we
see a nice Trend upward
which is a in this case across
five Cycles about seven percent uh per
year
and then uh we see the the big four
traits so we had uh Spike yield
and then this is a seed Mass
about three percent per year and I would
say this is the trait that's probably
had the least selection of the the four
important traits this had the least
selection emphasis uh on it percent free
threshing about 11 per year under the
last
two cycles I know that Lee has decreased
that selection intensity because we are
getting a lot of plants that are 90
percent pre-threshing uh so
changing uh Focus to to other variables
and then uh finally shattering uh less
shattering is is better so we see a nice
nice downward Trend across Cycles
so we've looked really at setting up the
genomic selection a pipeline and then
you know evaluating that pipeline the
last little bit that I want to talk
about is you know once we have a program
where everything is genotyped everything
is phenotyped and what all can we do
with that data
um and and one of the first things is uh
genome-wide Association studies
and the data I'll share is on tli Cycles
six through nine today if I were to go
do this I would have Cycles 6 through
13.
and it's about a thousand plants per
cycle and we're up to
well the the data I'll show is on about
4 000 plants today that database that
snowball keeps rolling we're up to about
8 000 phenotyped and genotyped plants
so all of the the data is there we can
go into a a g was very easily this is a
a Manhattan plot for seed shattering we
find you know some significant Peaks uh
2s and 4S interestingly the percent
variance explained by each one of these
Peaks are very small uh looking at those
four thousand plants I don't know if we
had a a giwas peak that explained more
than three percent of the variants
so since we have multiple breeding
Cycles then we can go back and say how
is this allele frequency changing so
this is a is a little bit more
validation that our GS is working as
well in this first box plot this is uh
for shattering on that 4S marker once we
ran the G was uh and then we estimated
the the allele effect very very additive
being heterozygous
I've yet to see a very strong
heterotic response most of our traits
respond very additively and this in this
case shattering higher shattering the
higher the score the higher the
shattering so we want to actually be low
here uh with this C and then we can put
together uh based on the the reference
genome how this allele frequency changed
in the population so we would like to
see more of the the snip C and then
starting in cycle six
uh the C is in the alternate it
increases uh you know from about 0.25
percent over uh 0.6 percent over those
three cycles and this was not uh this
was strictly based on the genomic
selection until we ran the G was I we
didn't know that this marker was
associated with shattering we weren't
selecting on it other than just being a
product of the of the genomic selection
model
another thing another trait brittle
racist we do find really strong Peaks on
3j
and this is a case I like to show all
the data again we see a very nice
additive allele effect where the lower
the score the less shattering and better
but when we look so we'd like to see
more of the the t-snip we actually see
that decreasing in the population
the only thing we can think of is that
this particular region has some linkage
drag or something that even with our GS
models we're we're not prioritizing that
particular snip
and I'd mentioned that our percent
variance explained was very small for
for all of our traits just using some uh
you know quantitative formulas you can
estimate the number of qtl that are
controlling things within
uh intermediate so we looked at brittle
rakis we should have been able to effect
to find a qtl at point that explained
0.9 percent of the variance
uh and based on that you know there's a
hundred maybe 166 qtl controlling
brittle rakers now this is very
interesting especially for the small
grains uh with barley the brittle rakis
is a very well studied system the btr1
the btr2 Gene and brittle rakis is
solved uh based on our our analytical
data we don't see that based on the
empirical data in the field
we don't have any main effect qtl we do
know that there are a lot of copy
numbers of this BTR Gene uh how they are
interacting how they are working not
really sure
is this number wrong absolutely but uh
it's
you know I don't know what the real
number will ever be but it's definitely
not a one or two or even a couple genes
system uh that is often associated with
brittle rakis in the small grains like
barley
so the and then the this slide
what I want to show with this is you
know we've got this big data set we've
got it stuff that's genotype we've got
phenotypes sometimes it's just asking
questions of the data this particular
data set
um The npgs germplasm Collection was
genotype so we had that and we have
pretty good historical records we know
the Kearns of breeding program since the
1980s but we don't know which pis and it
would have been the pis that were used
to start the program so we just said
okay what you know can we identify from
molecular data where the the founders of
the the current Kerns of breeding
population are and this is a a map just
of the
um you know Black Sea Caspian Sea and
then there's three different color codes
the orange circles are areas are pis
that molecular data predicted to be the
founder of kernsa and historical data uh
had documented as the founders of kernsa
and I will say the the historical data
is very clear that they selected 20 a
sessions for intermating
the problem is that's the end of the
historical records we don't have which
20th sessions so so we've recreated that
based on the data from 40 years ago uh
so we see a lot of overlap right here
the purple triangles are pis that
molecular data suggested was the
founders and then the the green
triangles or excuse me green Diamonds
Are a sessions that we estimated from
the historical record but overall
there's a lot of concurrence especially
right here in this Russia region between
the Black Sea and Caspian Sea I believe
it's the staff report I hope I said that
correct region that most of our Kern's
uh varieties uh come from from that area
and then the the last thing uh just the
future where where are we going with
some of this work what's the the next
big thing and this might I don't know if
if some of Jesse's talk last week might
have mentioned some of this but skim
sequencing High throughput uh Escape
sequencing what we're trying to do is
move our marker platform away from GBS
to uh something that will scale with the
new systems and also avoids any any
proprietary issues
so this was done uh Jesse was the
was the lead Pi on this using uh very
low skim sequencing so think .05 X
coverage to identify introgressions into
wheat
um
so that worked really well to
identifying aggressions when you look at
these two systems I just put this
together moving when you start thinking
about whole genome sequencing
most of the intermediates been on GBS
we get a thousand to two thousand
chromosome per markers 30 to 40 000
genome-wide with tassel pipeline very
easy to analyze the data we do have lots
of missing data so all of the
predictions that I showed were made with
up to 70 percent missing data per per
marker
uh with skim sequencing we've went from
a reduced representation to a whole
genome looking at 0.05 X coverage so
that gets us down to
an affordable level to sequence in the
breeding program and there are no
duplicate reads I mean most reads are a
single read but across populations we
can get three to four million variants
per chromosome so we went from working
on 40 000 markers up to like 80 million
and I put this together I didn't know
how else to say it I mean right now it's
a
different set of software you know one
piece for filtering one piece for doing
the next analysis and pipelining all
that together and then I would say we've
got even more missing data than GBS if
we thought we had a lot of missing data
under that
so in the last couple of weeks and
social staff at the the postdoc at the
land Institute has been working on a lot
of this he's really helped move this
forward uh the last couple of weeks I
feel like we've kind of had a
breakthrough on on moving toward this
method and I just want to show so this
is a a g was Peak
or excuse me Manhattan plot or brittle
rakis on that chromosome 3G 3j using GBS
markers
and we had about 2 000 markers uh here
and we have really good Peaks uh around
120 million base pairs uh 160 and those
correspond we do know that the BTR genes
are right in those areas
so taking the the skim seek data just
that alone
.05x coverage uh this is a another
analysis of brittle rakis
we actually start to see really good
Peaks that are lining up with our GBS
markers and maybe even a little bit
cleaner resolution throughout and all of
these areas this is the 120 160 280. we
have found through G was GBS markers in
in those spots so this is uh really
promising that uh I think that we can
make this work as a way forward for
affordable sequencing and we'll have a
lot more data for for different
analysis
so just in in summary uh with genomic
selection we can really decrease our
cycle time
in intermediate wheatgrass all of our
traits are really polygenic we don't see
any major effect qtls
and using all that data we can do a lot
of different analysis even analysis that
we don't start out to do we've just got
a huge data set that a lot of times we
can answer a question if if we parse it
correctly and then finally uh
breeding programs just require teams of
expertise my part's been the
bioinformatics the data management
and a lot of the the phenotypic datas
came from from lead on
and with that again I'd like to thank a
lot of fundings came from the land
Institute Malone family land
preservation foundation in the ffar
program as well
and it's I'm sure I've missed people but
it takes a lot of people to be able to
present that and I want to acknowledge
all of their work
uh what's correlation they Spike yield
and yield for unit area
also would you look at inbreeding
pressure
okay so the the question is correlation
between Spike yield like on a single
plant and what would be more like a plot
what a farmer would Harvest
I think those are pretty good Lee had
did a lot of work on this
2005 2010 looking at single plants
versus plots and that's why he initially
started with
um you know single plants why work we
are moving
um
to a lot more half sib family evaluation
so full plots we've you know kind of
tweaked what I've shown there to where
now we can plant a a full half sib
family and that's actually
probably in the future going to be more
informative in our GS models than the
single plant work
and I don't really have exact numbers
but I know every time I've heard Lee
talk about it he says the correlation
was high enough that he felt comfortable
going to single plants
perfect
yeah
we have not estimated particularly I I
know
you can tell that the later Cycles are
more inbred uh
when we make our genomic relationship
Matrix I don't have a value but across
000 markers and five or six Generations
only
less than 300 have been fixed in the
population
so
[Music]
I'll be the most other crops they have
integral prediction possible place as
that even tossed around to estimate
values on stuff made it on the pis or
from other obsessions whereas that seem
to cut out
so so since we have the
the the blobs or the predicted values on
intermediate have we tried to
predict back to what's in grin or
oh
we we've looked a lot of the wild
assessions
um
you know there's about 400 total in npgs
I know occasionally and it's been a
couple years Lee will bring in some new
material uh but right now we've had
enough genetic diversity there's still a
ton of diversity that we really haven't
pulled stuff in but we have evaluated
some in like the npgs collection there's
definitely different groups
because intermediate wheatgrass was bred
also prior to this as a forage erosion
control crop so there's differences in
you know biomass production versus seed
production even within that
the
so the the selected parents then do go
back to the field
I haven't really used them because
there's they're actually cloned I mean I
do a lot of checks like the the
histograms I was showing you and we do
see that a lot uh that the parents are
usually performing better in the way we
want but with the clonal data I haven't
used that particularly in the malls I
think there's a chance that could change
we do a spatial correction with ar1 by
ar-1 and I know for like grain yield
if we stack all of the parents on the
side instead of being randomly allocated
you know where we're going to buy us our
model too
so I don't
the
that I mean the the selected parents
if nothing else you know the following
cycle a thousand plants are going to go
into the field which should capture
everything there so we could be losing a
little bit but we're going to be picking
it up
in the next cycle anyway
so how many cycles of selection and
depends on where the the end goal is uh
or a product that farmers could grow I
mean you know there's the University of
Minnesota has released a variety
and I think they're coming out with
their second release
if you look at targeting saying annual
wheat uh
yield so equivalent yield whether you
grew the perennial or annual I think the
um the last estimates we were at were
about 20 years of 40 Cycles
but that also
[Music]
assumes that the rate of genetic gain is
going to be constant every year that we
don't uh
get to inbred or or lose too much
diversity as well which at this point we
haven't seen But predicting out 20 years
is challenging
yeah so so our our genomic selection is
working but our G was is you know less
than optimal uh
really the only thing we know is is we
think most traits are just highly highly
polygenic that
we're looking at very small trade
effects where our our GS model just
captures all of that and isn't trying to
test for significance of a single marker
oh
yeah
yeah so so the the G wasp was about 4
000 plants so it was the the training
population across
five cycles of selection
so data representing about six or seven
calendar years
and it was pooled uh so multiple years
of observation in in the model and then
one uh blah per
Janet per per plant so each each plant
was kept genotyped separately and had
its unique uh predicted blop that went
in the model
so we had about 4 000 plants go in uh
and then those blobs
depending on the cycle would have either
had one up to four years of observations
uh
so
we do know the the maternal plant and
then
that 100 selected the the breeding
program is the the pots are growing in
the greenhouse turn the fans on and blow
a big pollen cloud of those hundred
plants shuffle them around so we don't
do any targeted crosses but then we also
using the GBS markers we can assign
eternity so we do track the pedigree and
I know selections we try to keep you
know too many of the the same family or
maternal line we haven't you know
optimal contribution we haven't went
there but we do try to
uh at least at a baseline level keep
everything from coming from one family
and I know Lee has said before so this
was tli cycle six and before you know he
was using basically pedigree meat
pedigree breeding and a lot of times the
the top lines would all come out of the
same family
um
so we we do with the markers we do get
better resolution than that
um
the cost wise as far as the genotyping
say genomic selection prediction per
sample is about
probably totaled ten dollars or less
per per plant yes and we're genotyping
4 000 to 4 400 plants so it's
forty to fifty thousand dollars per
cycle
just for the the genomic side that's not
counting the
the labor and and the greenhouse you
know work as well
uh
yeah
no I'll stay away from that question no
uh yeah I don't
total cost yeah
would be very challenging and
intermediate also you know this it
started
the the identification of intermediate
it started Leaps and Bounds ahead of
many wild species I mean The rodel
Institute evaluated
150 different species and they selected
intermediate as you know the the one
that was closest
to to being able to domesticate or I say
closest you could also think maybe the
easiest if we fix a few things and it
already has a flavor profile and
um
so it's also going to depend on where
that species is starting how many things
do you have to fix you know
interestingly in like the the npgs's
sessions
and the ones that were coming out of the
that Russia region some of those are
marked down as cultivar
or as a cultivated species they're not
wild that they were planted no we don't
have any more records than that exactly
what that means but
you know whether there was been humor
human intervention in the past I don't
know but it's I would say intermediate
started closer to a crop than than some
of the other species that have been
evaluated and worked on
so you're contemplating changing Market
platforms right for DPS to to sequencing
how are you planning on so you're gonna
have to sort of Disconnect between your
historical data and speed data doing
markification or what yeah so the the
last slide I showed where the the G was
is starting to look good
um that was the you know the first
hurdle was making sure that we thought
our imputations were good and
ideally we had planned on this cycle
being to skim seek but that is that is
the hurdle is
for that previous training population
six Generations imputing those GBS
markers I mean basically a whole genome
imputation just using those markers
so that's still
that's still the work in progress that's
been kind of our hold up in in moving
forward
that's yes that's that's the plan I
don't know how it will work in practice
I I do know uh you know like uh Steve
Larson his group is breeding stuff and
you know he's actually starting his
first cycles of selection so he's
starting with like a fresh white board
and you know what I showed with skim
seat there is all he needs because he's
starting with that and he's off to go
changing platforms is yeah it's it's a
challenge for
for any program but for this especially
you know
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu